holy cow guys think story here with
another American Gods breakdown where we
take a deep dive into every episode so
if you haven't subscribed yet make sure
to hit that button with the Bell on
because here we go at the end of the
last episode shadow was kidnapped by who
I guess would be mr. town and yes mister
world's henchman mr. town who seems to
be some sort of CIA guy has shadow
hooked up to this machine this machine
will not only torture him but also be
able to delve into shadows memories
mr. town wants to know why Wednesday has
such a keen interest in this supposedly
mortal man and I have a few theories
about that which I'll get into in a bit
back at the motel America the gods have
put old Zorua who was shot to death last
episode in the back of the truck chair
nabob remarks on the rituals that must
be done to mark her passing like ringing
the bell covering the mirrors and the
sprinkling of the holy salt this in
preparation for summoning the new zoria
but as Chernabog swears his revenge to
the new gods casting them to the deepest
darkness of the nine hells he points out
that summoning zoria will not be
possible so Roya has no followers left
and thus her death is permanent I also
think it's interesting how the gods
refer to Wednesday by different names
Chernabog calling him volton and Mamaji
calling him grim near volton also means
tree and odin was killed on one these
different names point to the fact that
these gods have been around for so long
that they're known by many different
aliases over different cultures and
times Wednesday ask mama gee if he can
count on her blades in the war to come
and she rightfully lashes out at him
last episode she was on the fence about
joining this war but now the war has
come to them and she has no choice mama
G tells the jinn to go to the Corn
Palace and ask for old ik Tomi in Lakota
mythology it told me is a spider
trickster spirit and a cultural hero for
the Lakota people he somehow has access
to or knowledge of the whereabouts of
Odin's spear gun near which translates
to the swaying one it's clear that
preparations are underway for battle and
Odin will need his spear the jinn is
also referred to here as ifrit a type of
jinn from Arabic lore that can be either
good or evil and it seems for Loras all
in her own
save shadow the gods are too busy
preparing for battle to chase after a
mere mortal and that means Sweeney will
have to come laura has his precious coin
after all and he won't leave that behind
the Djinn allows Saleem to come visit
old ik Tomy with him and he seems pretty
happy to ride in this cute motorcycle
it'll be interesting to see where this
relationship between Selim and the jinn
goes because I'm not sure what they both
want from each other back in the torture
train mr. town continues his
interrogation he refers to Wednesday by
three different names cargo all-father
and grim i wouldnt have to start to
keeping a list just to keep track of
these shadow is asked why he joined the
old gods to which he mockingly replies
that he's a curious spirit but mr. town
isn't too concerned the machine will
help him see the truth we then get a
cool flashback transition from the
Statue of Liberty in shadows eyes too
young shadow and his mother on a ferry
coming to America notice how all the
flashbacks have a widescreen aspect
ratio just like the flashbacks which
started every episode of season one the
same flashbacks which depicted stories
of the gods and okay guys time for me to
put on my tinfoil hat here
what if shadow and his mother are both
gods and what if shadows mother is the
goddess of Liberty this scene takes
place overlooking the Statue of Liberty
and shadows mother even talks about it
being a depiction of the goddess
Libertas the Roman god of liberty and
freedom the Statue of Liberty was a gift
from France where both shadow and his
mother lived and which also happens to
be the birthplace of this modern day
conception of Liberty
Robespierre even said during the French
Revolution and what would later become
the motto of France
liberté égalité fraternité a liberty
equality fraternity they're coming back
to America just for the summer after
being on a world tour yet we never find
out what that really means in
considering the twin towers are still up
is this the summer of 2001 and does her
death coincide with 9/11 when freedoms
in America were suppressed in the name
of fighting terrorism and spreading
freedom if you're interested more on
this check out the Patriot Act and the
wiretapping scandal it's also
interesting to note that the building
which now stands where the twin towers
used to be is called the Freedom Tower
shadows mother makes several cryptic
comments like how the color of their
skin is
reminder of quote the history we remind
them oh this is a nod to how a country
founded on the principles of freedom and
liberty also simultaneously enslaved
millions of African Americans she also
makes a reference to shadow having a
light in fact she makes a reference to
him having like five different times in
this episode I can't help but think of
this Statue of Liberty's torch it's also
ironic that a boy named shadow would be
instilled with light then there's the
question of shadows father and it's
heavily hinted that Wednesday is the
real father making him the son of Odin
and Libertas or perhaps just some sort
of demigod when young shadow is at the
hospital he's visited by a man who
sounds a lot like Wednesday and also
does the coin trick which Wednesday also
knows how to do when young shadow is
beat up in the park the boys remark on
how he's practically a white boy the son
of a black woman and white man but I
want to hear what your guys theories are
in the comments below
back in Wisconsin Lauren Sweeney run
into more bad luck narrowly missing a
cow only to then hit a nail and get a
flat I also like how Sweeney still has
his cuffs on from when he was arrested
for allegedly killing Laura in season
one at blackbriar mister world pours
Bilquis a glass of scotch from his globe
shaped glass and of course it's focused
on North America he congratulate her for
a job well done but she tells him she
can't join him feeling guilty she can't
join either side after all as Bilquis
says nothing was ever quite
I always what I meant never meet mr.
world bluntly States bill quizzes
position she's shunned by the old gods
yet won't join the new what will become
of her in another flashback we see young
shadow reading Siddhartha a book which
follows a man in his spiritual journey
of self-discovery
just like how shadow is on his own
spiritual journey of self-discovery and
cool info the park where this is filmed
is about five minutes away from my house
when shadow is beat up one of the
bullies remarks you best stay in your
lane which older shadow echoes when
talking to mr. town while he's arrested
we get a blurry image of Jesus whom also
mimics the pose shadows in when he gets
tortured by mr. town this figure also
foreshadows the death of his mother when
we later get the unblurred version at
the church his mother tells them that
those boys and comps want the same
things we do to quote be valued and
matter in this world just like the gods
back in Wisconsin Laura uses her super
strength to hold up the car but it seems
to Sweeney that her powers are fading
after all she's slowly decomposing and
it's only a matter of time before she's
gone for good
at which time Sweeney can get his coin
back but Sweeney tells her there may be
a way to save her but it involves making
a deal with a devil in the French
Quarter of New Orleans but first they
must save shadow my guess is that will
be the next adventure for Laura and
Sweeney
technical boys on the search for median
one of the most media heavy places on
the planet Times Square but it's
actually Yonge Dundas Square in Toronto
where they shoot the show I doubt we'll
see Gillian Anderson the season as I've
heard she along with Kristin Chenoweth
did not sign on for the season so it'll
be interesting to see what happens with
this storyline Media has gone into
hiding scared of the old gods and tells
technical boys she needs to adapt in
order to survive in another flashback
young shadow is now reading a moveable
feast a memory by American author Ernest
Hemingway about his years as a
struggling young writer in Paris another
nod to France shadow is in the hospital
waiting for her mother and over the PA
we hear that a doctor is needed in
oncology so it's likely her mother has
some sort of cancerous tumor freedom and
liberty is slowly being eroded later we
get this shot of shadow with his mother
talking to someone on the phone she's
talking about shadow and how much
time she has left my guess is that
Wednesday is on the other end
shadow uses his anger and frustration to
take out a group of bullies anger and
hate his mother told him not to give in
to still at least this violence was done
in the name of something good Laura and
Sweeney reach a dead end
get it dead end and just when it looks
like all his loss Sweeney conveniently
says there may be another way to catch
up to shadow going through the Horde
this is a leprechaun trick in which
Sweeney manipulates time and space
allowing them to travel right above the
bridge where shadows train is passing
now there are some cool little tidbits
here first and this could just be a
production error Laura's eyes have gone
back to normal as if she isn't dead here
second we get these glimpses of green
and gold the colors commonly associated
with leprechauns we also get the sounds
of coins dropping and this shot of
Sweeney and Laura naked now this could
mean two things one foreshadowing an
eventual relationship between them or
two this is a flashback from season 1
where we learn about Sweeney's Irish
love se McGowan who's also played by
Emily Browning I think it'll be a safe
bet that something will happen between
these two they jump on the train where
shadow is standing on a Vulcan container
Vulcan you'll remember as the God who
embraced firearms and became the weapons
dealer in order to survive in the 21st
century
mr. Towne asked how shadow made its snow
back in season 1 but shadow says it
never happened either he's lying or he
still doesn't believe in himself and in
our final flashback with young shadow
shadows mother passes away the coin
falling brandishing the words Liberty
before it shatters it coinciding with
her death the death of Liberty at church
we see shadow struggling a mix of anger
and sadness we also get this brief shot
of older shadow as he turns signifying
his transition from boy to man a new
chapter in his life and in one of the
most cryptic scenes of this episode
Wednesday sacrifices his car to an
oncoming train and makes a rambling
speech about Betty the Barbarian a
berserker who will take her place in
Valhalla the table of the hooded one the
hooded one another name for Odin my
guess is that his car is the
reincarnation of his warhorse and in
order for it to be reincarnated again to
something new it must be sacrificed the
final shot even shows through Odin's
dead eye the
car being smashed and the sounds and
figure of a horse galloping towards him
and finally we have Laura and Sweeney
who make quick work of mr. towns thugs
in order to get to shadow and also one
of the most brutal head crushing scenes
ever
she tells shadow she had to save him and
now with him saved we'll see if they
head off to Louisiana in search of that
devil that could save her life thanks
for watching everyone make sure to give
this video a like and hit that subscribe
button I'm planning to do a breakdown
for every episode so you're not gonna
want to miss it also check out my
episode 1 breakdown if you haven't seen
it and follow me on twitter at think
story whitey until next time remember
daddy loves you very much